good morning Hank it's Tuesday recently
I was researching Dorothea Lange's
famous migrant mother photograph and I
learned something that was never covered
in any of my US history classes which is
that during the Great Depression the
United States deported at least 400,000
and possibly as many as 2 million
mexican-americans most of whom were US
citizens this came to be known as the
Mexican repatriation although as
scholars have pointed out since many of
the people involved had never lived in
or even been to Mexico it was more of a
deep a tree Asian ok a bit of historical
context in the mid 19th century the
United States took a bunch of land from
Mexico including all of California and
Arizona as a result of the
mexican-american war and the Gadsden
Purchase and the people who lived in
those communities who had been Mexican
citizens became US citizens then in the
early 20th century the violence and
economic disruption of the Mexican
Revolution led lots of people to seek
refuge in the United States also the
border between the u.s. and Mexico
wasn't formally regulated until 1917
right so it's 1930 the Great Depression
is under way unemployment is rising as
is anti-immigrant sentiment and the
administration of President Herbert
Hoover is promising real jobs for real
Americans and Hoover's labor secretary
believes that deportations will decrease
unemployment a line of thinking that has
proven extraordinarily durable even
though it isn't true like national
economies are not some zero-sum game
where removing people from the workforce
creates jobs in fact a 20-17 study about
the Mexican repatriation found that the
deportations either had no effect on
unemployment or else made it slightly
worse by the way links to sources in the
doobly-doo also I know contemporary
conversations about US immigration are
highly polarized but I think it's
important to note that in the 30s the
push for deportations came from both
what would today be considered the left
and the right like many labor unions
called for deportations for instance but
so did the conservative Hoover
administration amid all of this local
municipalities began rounding up
Mexicans or Americans of Mexican descent
or at times anyone judged to have brown
skin police officers or other officials
would surround parks or neighborhoods
where Mexican Americans lived and then
take people on to trucks and drive them
to Mexico or else drive them to train
stations where chartered trains took
them to Mexico
now these deportations took many forms
some were caused by a mix of coercion
and discrimination
for instance many cities passed laws
saying that mexican-americans couldn't
work for city governments the federal
government also encouraged large private
companies to fire their mexican-american
workers which many companies did but
there were also other strategies to
force people out of the US like for
instance some hospital patients were
literally wheeled out of hospitals and
put onto trucks and driven to Mexico
there were sometimes legal proceedings
and if you could prove citizenship which
many people couldn't because such
documentation was uncommon at the time
you might be allowed to stay but you
also might not it varied dramatically
from city to city and it was extremely
chaotic but in general those threatened
with deportation had almost no legal
recourse and as a result at a minimum
hundreds of thousands of US citizens
were deported to Mexico the US
government has never apologized for the
repatriation and it's not even mentioned
in most US history textbooks and this
isn't like ancient history there are
lots of people alive today who lived
through this one of them for instance
was a five year old boy named Jose Lopez
who despite being born in Detroit was
deported in fact when he got to Mexico
he was teased because he didn't speak
Spanish
Jose Lopez's parents would go on to die
in exile as did one of his siblings but
he returned to the United States in 1944
after trying to prove his citizenship
for 14 years he worked for his entire
career at Ford Motor Company became a
home owner and a dedicated volunteer in
his community all three of his kids went
to college one is now an attorney but
there is also no getting back everything
that whoomp has lost as a result of his
unjust and illegal deportation Lopez is
American and his story is an American
story and telling that story will never
be unpatriotic Hank I'll see you on
Friday